on the top of a dark and distant  mountain there is a beautiful and  talented woman who uses her unique  skills to create hauntingly disturbing  confections  she finds beauty in the art of darkness  with each creation and shares them with  us the unusual creatures she has taken  in the world I can't remember the last  time we had a normal meal around here  you think this meal is normal at a  spectacular once this cools down we'll  be ready to carve a face I use royal  icing and a piping bag can I help  [Music]  you're a pretty little princess don't  wait up this is our home and it's a  place for the strange and unusual  are safe and welcome welcome to the  curious creations of Christine  I do think we should kill him with  kindness  oh that takes so long  you